[Music]
i'm out here looking for
something
despite the well being in the state it
is
valkyrie
ragnarok tears our world asunder
all we hold precious
lies
[Music]
[Music]
i've already lost my homeland
and the people i love
[Music]
you would have me battle
even in death
glory
i've now interest in that
there's nothing left for me in this
world
i just want a chance to make things
right
my name is christopher i have protected
this land and its people as my
forefathers did before me
very well then i pledge my loyalty as
your inheriar until the very end
you are a being of divine power are you
not please would you hear my plea
my name is tyko
it was once my duty to watch over this
land
[Music]
wretched soul
by odin's command
you shall be purified
so this is one of the four gifts
if i had to guess
i'd say this was
divine
please allow me to conduct a small test
of your metal
so we meet at last little valkyrie i
have no intention of harming you
i failed to warn you of her our
adversary was once a second class i see
her she goes by the name
fenrir
i i merely wish for the world to
continue existing
you